i am so excited about this segment with
michelle who is going on her first date
after divorce i have been there this is
personal for me
we set her up with our good friend of
the show dating expert demona hoffman
we set her up with lee harris who is the
amazing stylist i work with
i know lauren and tony did her hair and
makeup
and we actually got to go and be a third
wheel
on michelle's date so um let's see
how she took in all of our words of
wisdom
guidance advice thoughts feelings and
applied it
let's check it out
so here i am i'm about to have our
picnic lunch which i'm really excited
about
and i have some special tips from devona
so i'm good um
so yeah i'm a little nervous a little
excited but
let's go see how this goes hi michelle
how are you it's so nice to meet you
nice to meet you too
amazing wow dress looks terrific on you
brings out your eyes i love it
thank you great kind of easy when you
have juice glam squad
that's awesome tell me about yourself so
i was born and raised in the city
but um we moved to san francisco after
my mom had a new job out there so i
lived there for 10 years
so i grew up on long and i relocated to
boston
about 20 years ago nice oh yeah
my daughter's 13 and she's definitely
becoming her own person so that's been
an adjustment for me
to appreciate that yes i could totally
relate to that because i
too have a 13 year old and i don't know
if i would say she's coming into her
own home but she's definitely testing
her waters i can certainly say that
so do you date much this is my first
date
ever since getting divorced okay so how
do you feel dating has changed
i think i don't go in with any
expectations or any high hopes or
anything i mean i'm just looking for
someone who likes that fun
yeah so yeah that's good yeah that's
that's really good i like it too that's
yeah
a lot of the similarities i'm i'm big
with being
being outdoors you know especially when
the weather's nice
michelle was really nice meeting you i
had great conversation
thank you likewise yeah
um by the way how weird is it to like do
everything with cameras in your face
i don't know how you do it it was very
strange
but cameras aside did you get just even
the slightest
feeling about ronnie um yeah i mean i
think you
i absolutely could tell he was a very
nice guy i thought his questions were
really interesting and showed he cared
he also perked up when you were like i'm
just looking to have fun he was like oh
great
yeah jackpot jackpot he was like the
pressure's off when i sat down to talk
with you
i sort of just felt like we were gonna
have an energized good
healthy conversation about a subject
that's extremely
interesting to me because i'm in the
same boat yeah
but what i didn't expect was to have
not one michelle but two
aha moments with you yeah that was
incredible
the first being that we
get so conditioned in a flight pattern
of
concern guilt fear worry
of this wasn't the plan right you know
it's interesting you say
flight plan because i think that that's
what we've all been conditioned and it's
very meticulous like you grow up you get
married you have kids and it's just this
one course that we're all supposed to be
on because that's the way the world has
taught us
but i think that like you're saying to
kind of start taking that apart and
saying okay that might be somebody
else's journey but that's not mine
you know we when we started talking
about you know upcoming holidays or how
we're dividing this i was like whoa
i'm an only child you take my kids away
like i'm gonna lose it up nobody i'm
like okay
i've gotten through words we're gonna
we're gonna be okay and
to hear about that i think like i'm
gonna be all alone
i feel like we just need to kind of fall
in love with ourselves
like actually i like being alone it's
gonna be okay
i think that that's what we all really
need to get used to i
i so relate i really really really
relate
and i think that trying to date after
that
almost comes with all of that
dauntingness of it's gonna be this big
avalanche again and am i ready to buckle
up
and take all that on again and again
michelle
there was the second aha moment where
i'm like
what am i talking about i'm never
getting married again never
never ever ever i can't do it
and i'm not having children with anyone
again
right no oh no the shop's closed yeah
we're done
um so if we're not getting married again
and we're not having children again all
of a sudden these
albatrosses these pressures these
fears these big ticket items won't be
there
right so i've never seen it with that
clarity and perspective
that i haven't actually thought about
how light and easy just some dating
could be
yeah without the flight plan i just i
feel
slightly transformed since we've spoken
i'm happy and i don't know if i did
anything for you are you kidding me and
ever since i talked to you i'm like
i don't know yes maybe i could go on her
today yeah maybe
you go girl yeah by the way do you think
you'll see ronnie again or
we just i don't i think i mean he's a
really nice guy i think it would be fun
i love it i mean yeah we're sure exactly
i've waited my whole life to be this
easy going
wow so thank you michelle thank you
thank you so much it's really nice to
get to know you
you